und jetzt das heute journal mit Gundula
Gause und eine Gellinek
guten Abend der Schlagabtausch in der
Ampelkoalition geht munter weiter die
grüne Ministerin die den Fehlstart der
Regierung nach der Sommerpause ausgelöst
hatte indem sie ein Gesetz des
fdp-kollegen kurzerhand blockierte legte
heute noch mal nach nach drei Tagen
kamerascheue beräumte Lisa Paus für den
Nachmittag ein Pressestatement an und
forderte mehr Geld die Kinder
Grundsicherung sei Zitat das wichtigste
sozialpolitische Projekt dieser
Regierung Punkt der Kanzler tat das was
er immer tut er scholzte seine
Einmischung erst habe dafür gesorgt dass
das Gesetz nun so gut wie fertig sei und
58 Prozent der Bürger sagen im ZDF
Politbarometer dass die Regierung ihre
Arbeit eher schlecht machen Klaus
Brodbeck über Tag 3 des Ampel Tumults
wie einsam sich PolitikerInnen in
bestimmten Momenten fühlen wie dünn sie
selbst das Eis einschätzen auf dem Sie
sich gerade bewegen wie gefährlich es
also womöglich im Moment für sie ist
wird auch deutlich wenn sie
pressesprechersätze sagen lassen wie
diesen ich bitte darum um Verständnis da
wir das kurzfristig anberaumt haben dass
es danach keine Zeit für Rückfragen geht
wir müssen das in den Kalender der
Ministerin reinquetschen deswegen Frau
Ministerin bitte ihr Statement die
Ministerin liest vom Blatt Lisa Paus
spricht über ihr wichtigstes Projekt
viel sagen aber wie sie heute nicht
vor gemeinsam mit verschiedenen
berechnungsvarianten hierzu kann ich
Ihnen heute leider keine weiteren
Informationen geben da diese wie Sie
wissen regierungsintern verhandelt
werden und dafür bin ich schon
Verständnis 3 Stunden zuvor gegen Mittag
der Kanzler in Salzburg Scholz antwortet
auf Fragen sinngemäß alles mit gut
die Fragen der Kindergrundsicherung da
habe ich hier sehr dafür gesorgt dass es
einen großen Fortschritt gibt und wie
ich schon bei verschiedenen Gelegenheit
gesagt haben wir sind mit 99 Prozent
vielleicht sind es nur 98 je nachdem was
man zählt fertig den Rest schaffen wir
auch noch die Ministerin unter Druck
nimmt das als Bestätigung der
Koalitionspartner hält dagegen
der Bundeskanzler hat deutlich gemacht
dass die Kinder Grundsicherung nicht nur
sicherstellen sollen dass alle die
Anspruch auf staatlich Unterstützung
haben diese auch erhalten sondern dass
die Kindergrundsicherung auch
Leistungsverbesserungen enthält der
Haushalt ist begrenzt und am Ende muss
alles das was wir im Sozialstaat
ausgeben von den Menschen in Deutschland
erwirtschaftet werden das darf eben
niemand vergessen und einfach nur
Sozialleistung zu erhöhen das bekämpft
ja keine Kinderarmut bessere
Bildungschancen sind die Antwort da tun
wir schon einiges dieser Pause liest
noch mehr vor von einem
Paradigmenwechsel einer Bringschuld des
Staats gegenüber Bedürftigen von
Bürokratie Abbau und einer digital wie
sozialpolitischen Revolution all das in
fünfeinhalb Minuten sie spricht von
einer Kinder Grundsicherung ehrlich
gesagt weiß ich nicht mehr was sie damit
überhaupt meinte in jedem Interview
nennt sie andere Zahlen in jedem
Interview fügt sie andere Begriffe
zusammen es ist überhaupt keine Linie
erkennbar die Familien in Deutschland
haben einen Anspruch darauf dass wir
dieses seit Jahrzehnten ungelöste
Problem endlich lösen herzlichen Dank
vielen Dank Frau Ministerin vielen Dank
für Ihre Zeit am Nachmittag und vor dem
Wochenende tschüss
sind keinerlei Fragen stellen
zu fragen bliebe genug was weiter fehlt
sind Antworten
500.000 Soldaten eine halbe Million
Menschen sollen inzwischen im Ukraine
Krieg auf beiden Seiten verwundet worden
oder gestorben sein das schätzt die
amerikanische Regierung laut Bericht der
New York Times die Betonung liegt auf
schätzt es scheint als ob die gegen
Offensive der Ukraine ins Stocken
geraten ist darüber sprechen wir gleich
mit der stellvertretenden ukrainischen
Verteidigungsministerin zuvor aber
stellt uns unsere Reporterin eine Brühl
die Frau vor die den Schrecken des
Krieges täglich in Worte fassen muss
ein selfie mit Hanna Malia für viele
Ukrainer ist die stellvertretende
Verteidigungsministerin das Gesicht
dieses Kriegs sie kommuniziert die
Nachrichten von der Front die guten und
die schlechten auch an ihr geht das
nicht spurlos vorüber oh wie na du
verändert einen sehr stark der Krieg
hinterlässt innere Wunden die nie
geheilt werden das ist eine Tragödie
meines Staates meiner Heimat
vor dem Krieg sagt sie und zeigt uns
Bilder habe ich immer nur Röcke getragen
ich sag mal die Frau habe ich begraben
die gibt es nicht mehr
jetzt trägt die Juristin Uniform trifft
Frontkämpfer in der Region rakif über
ihr fliegen russische Drohnen während
sie der Einheit den persönlichen Dank
des Präsidenten überbringt
handgeschrieben
für uns sind diese Begegnungen mit
militärleuten immer sehr emotional und
ich versuche ihn immer sehr aufrichtig
meine Begeisterung und Dankbarkeit
auszudrücken
selbst vor Ort sein dass es dir wichtig
nur so sagt sie bekomme sie das ganze
Bild
und im Osten der Ukraine sind wir jetzt
mit Hanna Malia verbunden
stellvertretende ukrainische
Verteidigungsministerin guten Tag
dorthin Frau Malia sie sind heute morgen
noch an der Front gewesen und haben dort
Soldaten besucht wir hören seit längerem
dass die ukrainische Gegenoffensive
stockt und die russische Armee sogar die
Stadt zurückerobern könnte wie schwierig
ist die Lage für die ukrainische Armee
vor Ort
es ist wirklich so dass ich heute morgen
an der Front war
guten Morgen plane ich ebenfalls dort zu
sein aber da besuche ich dann andere
Einheiten die Situation im Osten ist
angespannt weil die Russische Föderation
darauf gesetzt hat dass es ein
offensiver im Osten gibt und sie haben
weiterhin dieses Ziel sie verfolgen es
weiterhin dass sie dieses Gebiet
behalten deswegen haben sie sich weiter
aktiviert sie setzen darauf dass es in
der Richtung weiter aktiver
Kampfhandlungen gibt und die Russen
versuchen weiter in die Offensive zu
gehen aber es ist ihnen nicht gelungen
Gelände gewinnen zu haben und deswegen
haben sie es nicht geschafft dieses Ziel
zu erreichen Richtung zu gehen die
ukrainischen Streitkräfte haben sie
aufgehalten was wir aber jetzt sehen ist
dass die Russen sich neu gruppieren sie
haben jetzt neue Einheiten neue Waffen
um wieder diese Aktivität aufzunehmen
sowohl in Richtung Kopien als auch in
Richtung
nehmen sie uns noch mal mit an die Front
wie ist die Lage der Soldaten wie viele
Verluste gibt es wie schwer sind die
Kämpfe dort
auch im Süden das ist die wichtigste
Offensive der wichtigste Schwerpunkt der
Offensive auch im Osten ist die
Situation schwierig da gibt es
verschiedene Richtungen wo die Russen
ihrer offensiver starten und die
ukrainische Armee hat ebenfalls eine
offensive die Situation ist schwierig
die Situation ist ähnlich überall gibt
es Kampfhandlungen die sehr angespannt
sind die ukrainischen Streitkräfte
vernichten den Gegner wir vernichten
sowohl ihr offensiver Potenzial als auch
ihre verteidigungspotenzial und alles
danke Unterstützung unserer westlichen
Partner denn das gelingt uns den Waffen
die wir von den westlichen Partnern
bekommen und natürlich ist es auch die
Professionalität und der Mut unserer
Soldaten
jeden Tag hat man das Gefühl dass die
Nachrichten gleich sind mehrere Monate
lang berichten wir dass es
Kampfhandlungen gibt
in der Realität stehen hinter diesen
einfachen Worten nicht nur
Kampfhandlungen sondern ist das auch oft
so dass die Positionen sich im Laufe des
Tages ändern die Positionen der
Einheiten einige Stellungen versucht der
Feind einzunehmen dann werden diese
Stellungen wieder zurückerobert und die
Situation ändert sich manchmal mehrfach
am Tag westliche Geheimdienste berichten
immer häufiger dass die Ukraine in die
Defensive geraten ist das im Moment die
russische Armee stärker vorrückt stimmt
das
Russland gibt das ist meistens der
Ostens aber es gibt auch Richtungen wo
die Ukraine in die Offensive geht das
ist bachmut das ist der Süden natürlich
ist das ein sehr schwieriger Krieg denn
die Ukraine müssen den Krieg unter den
Bedingungen führen wo die Russen unsere
Gegner deutlich mehr Personal haben
deutlich mehr Soldaten auch deutlich
mehr Waffen
unter solchen Bedingungen führt man in
der Regel ja keine Offensive an aber es
gelingt uns diese offensiver zu führen
deswegen ist es wichtig hier die Erfolge
nicht nur in Metern oder Kilometern
schmeißen sondern in der Tatsache selbst
dass man unter solchen Bedingungen es
schafft eine Offensive zu führen noch
eine Frage zu den westlichen
Waffenlieferungen die Amerikaner haben
ihr Okay gegeben dass die Niederlande
und Dänemark amerikanische F16
Kampfflugzeuge in die Ukraine liefern
können über die deutschen Taurus
Marschflugkörper wird immer noch
diskutiert in Deutschland gibt noch
keine Entscheidung könnten solche Waffen
denn eine entscheidende Wendung in
diesem Krieg bringen oder kommen sie
viel zu spät
eine Entscheidung der Wände können
Wasserlieferungen bringen
und das sind die Positionen wo die
Russische Föderation einen Vorrang hat
Russland hat ein Vorrang in der Luft
deswegen brauchen wir entsprechend
Flugzeuge
die Russen haben ebenfalls mehr Raketen
deswegen gibt es in der Ukraine gar
keinen sicheren Ort im ganzen Land
dementsprechend brachen brauchen wir
Raketenabwehrsysteme und wir brauchen
natürlich auch
Waffen mit großer Reichweite denn da
haben Russen ebenfalls einen Vorrang
und so können wir die besetzten Gebiete
befreien die wir befreien möchten die
Rede geht nur um die ukrainischen
Territorien Waffen werden nicht auf den
Territorien anderer Staaten eingesetzt
genau das ist eine große Sorge in
Deutschland dass mit Waffen die große
Reichweite besitzen russisches
Territorium angegriffen werden könnte
das können sie wirklich ausschließen
seit dem Jahr 2014 und auch seit dem
Start des vollflächigen Krieges am 24
Februar halten wir uns an alle Normen
des internationalen Rechts und auch an
die Kriegsführung an alle Richtlinien
dementsprechend wird der Kampf nur im
Rahmen unseres Territoriums geführt und
das Ziel ist unsere besetzten Gebiete zu
befreien die Ukraine hat
keinen Wunsch dass Territorium des
Nachbarstaates anzugreifen auf gar
keinen Fall wir kämpfen nur im Rahmen
unserer Grenzen
Hanna Malia war das stellvertretende
Verteidigungsministerin der Ukraine
herzlichen Dank für das Gespräch
und das Gespräch haben wir aus
Sicherheitsgründen am Nachmittag
aufgezeichnet und wir bleiben beim Thema
Sicherheitspolitik und schauen diesmal
in Richtung Pazifik damit beginnen die
Nachrichten von Gundula Gause den USA
Japan und Südkorea geht es um die
Festigung ihrer Partnerschaft und die
Sicherheit im indupazifikraum das ist
die Botschaft die die drei Präsidenten
angesichts zunehmender Spannungen an
China und Nordkorea senden wollen auf
ihrem ersten dreiergipfel vereinbarten
US-Präsident beiden Japans
Regierungschef kishida und Südkoreas
Staatschef zuckiol in Camp David engere
Zusammenarbeit in den Bereichen
militärwirtschaft und Energiesicherheit
die drei Staaten Streben auch eine
engere Abstimmung in Krisen an
Bundeskanzler Scholz hat sich in
Salzburg gegen ein Ende der Kontrollen
an der österreichischen Grenze
ausgesprochen bei einem Treffen mit
Österreichs Bundeskanzler nehammer
verwies Scholz auf die geplante Reform
des europäischen Asylrechts bis dahin
müsste man sich aber pragmatisch helfen
so Scholz wie zum Beispiel an der
deutsch-österreichischen Grenze
Österreichs ehemaliger Kanzler kurz ist
wegen Verdachts der Falschaussage
angeklagt worden ihm wird vorgeworfen
vor dem Untersuchungsausschuss zur
sogenannten ibiza-affäre im Jahr 2020
gelogen zu haben als es um den eigenen
Einfluss auf die Besetzung eines
chefpostens bei einer österreichischen
Staats Holding ging das Verfahren soll
am 18 oktober in Wien beginnen kurz
drohen drei Jahre Haft
auf Teneriffa kämpfen weiterhin hunderte
Feuerwehrleute und Soldaten gegen einen
riesigen Waldbrand im Nordosten der
spanischen Insel die Feuer sind immer
noch nicht unter Kontrolle breiten sich
mittlerweile aber langsamer aus jetzt
stehen
3.800 Hektar in Flammen ungefähr ein
Drittel mehr Fläche als gestern nach
extremer Hitze und Trockenheit war der
Brand am Dienstag ausgebrochen 3000
Menschen wurden bereits in Sicherheit
gebracht
auch im Westen Kanadas müssen wegen
großer Waldbrände mehrere Städte und
Orte geräumt werden rund 20.000
Einwohner müssen die Regionalhauptstadt
yellowei verlassen per Auto oder
Flugzeug die katastrophenschutzchefin
hatte die komplette Evakuierung
angeordnet auch für killowna in British
Columbia wurde der Notstand ausgerufen
Kanada kämpft seit Monaten gegen
Waldbrände aktuell sind es rund 1.000 es
soll die verheerendste Waldbrandsaison
in Kanada seit Beginn der Aufzeichnungen
sein
vor ziemlich genau 60 Jahren im August
1963 wurde die Bundesliga erstmals
angepfiffen die Herren Fußballspieler
verdienten auch damals schon Geld aber
nicht so viel dass sie davon wirklich
leben konnten selbst ein Topstürmer wie
Uwe Seeler musste damals nebenher als
Vertreter für Sportartikel arbeiten
heute ist sie eine Liga der Millionäre
und der Langeweile geworden denn Meister
wird am Ende immer der FC Bayern aber
natürlich hat sie in 60 Jahren auch
unvergessliche Momente der Ball und
Wortakrobatik hervorgebracht Christian
von Rechenberg mit einer kritischen Oma
nun ist sie also 60 Jahre alt diese
Bundesliga jeder Spieltag seitdem ein
Hochamt jede Meisterschaft ein
Hochgefühl jeder Verein Heimat
Herzkammer Heiligtum seiner Fans oh wie
ist das schön sie ist auf eine sehr
angenehme Art und Weise gealtert besser
geworden erfahrener geworden hat viel
durchgemacht Skandale durchgemacht aber
am Ende
steht sie immer noch in voller Blüte da
die Bundesliga ist sicherlich nicht in
der Blüte ihrer Zeit sie ist ein
rüstiger Rentner und sie wird am Stock
gehen wenn in den nächsten zehn Jahren
weiterhin die Meisterschaft zwischen
Bayern und Dortmund aufgeteilt wird
morgen ist es soweit eine neue Epoche
des deutschen Fußballs wird beginnen
naja am Anfang ist der Meister noch
erste fC Köln und Anpfiff am ersten
Spieltag war erst um 17 Uhr als im
August so heiß ist das Tore schießen
kann beginnen eines schöner als das
beste Blaupausen für den Bolzplatz
der 70 Meter solo-lauf von Daniels
unvergessen wie auch dieses Spiel
1973 da haben die Bayern vier
Weltmeister im Team liegen gegen
Kaiserslautern klarfahren und verlieren
sie zu viel
heute sind die Bayern das Maß aller
Dinge längst eine Liga für sich geld
macht sexy und sichert Sieger das kann
dieser Verein schon bringen der kann die
Spieler schon groß machen auch für die
große Bühne die große Bühne beherrschten
die Bomber die Terrier die Ungeheuer und
wie sie alle mit Spitznamen hießen uns
Uwe Günter Netzer Unterschied Spieler
geformt von unterschiedstrainern wie
Heins weißweiler oder Latte man vermisst
sie heute in Zeiten mit denen der
deutsche Fußball hinkt
den Nationalteams geht beides ab Fortune
und Supertalente die holen die
Bundesliga für eine Liebe aus dem
Ausland Harry Kane top ausgebildet
besser ausgebildet als unser Nachwuchs
die 100 Millionen für Kane wenn du im
großen Konzert mitspielen willst sind
gut angebracht aber die Jugendarbeit das
ist ja ein ganz anderes Thema da liegt
es im Argen an der Wurzel diese
sensationelle WM in Brasilien hat uns
dazu verführt von unserem Konzept des
kämpfenden Fußballs abzugehen von der
Stärke der deutschen ein Spiel vom
Rückstand durch Kampf zu drehen und zu
gewinnen
gemeint ist der DFB der in Frankfurt
gebaut hat einen Fußballtempel für 180
Millionen das Signal wir sind Weltspitze
fragt sich mit welchen Personal man will
die Vereine in die Pflicht nehmen heißt
es in der Bundesliga künftig mehr auf
deutschen Nachwuchs zu setzen und die
Trainer besser schulen selten Einblicke
in einem Seminar des Team DFB bei den
u-mannschaften steht heute
spielbeschleunigung auf dem Lehrplan
rasch aufholen was bisher liegen blieb
die taktisierung hat in jungen Jahren
einfach dazu geführt dass wir nicht mehr
diese individuelle Qualität nicht mehr
diese trippler ausbilden wie wir sie uns
auf dem Platz wünschen und die auf den
Unterschied dann national wie auch
international machen und da müssen wir
zukünftig eher den Fokus draufsetzen und
auch darauf das Millionengeschäft
Bundesliga entfremde Fans und Vereine
die Schere zwischen den Superreichen
Vereinen und dem Rest ist nach 60 Jahren
so weit wie nie der DFB sieht das
Problem aber sich nicht zuständig und da
glaube ich muss die Bundesliga zusehen
auch perspektivisch dass man gesund
wächst und dass man dann auch schaut
dass man im internationalen Fokus
Konkurrenzfähigkeit die Bundesliga nach
60 Jahren ist sie also irgendwo zwischen
voller Blüte und rüstiger Rentnerin oh
wie ist das schön
und das Auftaktspiel ein echter
Klassiker Werder Bremen gegen Bayern
München in den letzten Minuten kurz vor
Spielende steht es 2:0 für den deutschen
Meister Hurricane schoss sein erstes Tor
für Bayern München
zum Auftakt der Hockey
Europameisterschaften in Mönchengladbach
hat die deutsche
Frauen-Nationalmannschaft 4:0 gegen
Schottland gewonnen das erste Tor für
Deutschland viel schon in der ersten
Minute durch Sonja Zimmermann die später
auch zum 3:0 traf das 4:0 erzielte
Charlotte starbenhorst die Herren Hockey
Nationalmannschaft aktueller Weltmeister
spielt morgen um 18 Uhr gegen Wales live
zu sehen in der ZDF Mediathek
hohe Baukosten und Zinsen belasten das
Baugewerbe laut Statistischen Bundesamt
wurde in der ersten Hälfte des Jahres
nur rund
135.000 neue Wohnungen genehmigt ein
Rückgang im Vorjahresvergleich und mehr
als 27%
bauverbände zeigen sich besorgt und
fordern ein deutliches gegensteuern der
Bundesregierung
in der Krise des chinesischen
Immobilienmarktes ist ein weiterer
Konzern dort in einem massive Schieflage
geraten der Projektentwickler evergreant
hat Gläubiger Schutz bei einem
us-insolvenzgericht beantragt Sina
meinets an der Frankfurter Börse wie
groß ist die Krise dieses
immobilienkonzerns sie ist schon immens
denn aber Grant ist mit umgerechnet rund
300 Milliarden Euro verschuldet und
damit höher als jeder andere
Immobilienkonzern weltweit
jahrzehntelang boomte der chinesische
Bausektor doch viele Firmen gerieten in
Schieflage 2020 führte Peking dann
Maßnahmen gegen die hohe Verschuldung
ein die Folge waren Bauruinen und
Insolvenzen die chinesische Baubranche
machte zeitweilig ein Drittel der
gesamten Wirtschaftsleistung Chinas aus
evergrand ist ein Schwergewicht und hat
nun Gläubiger Schutz in den USA
beantragt so schützt sich der Konzern
vor Klagen amerikanischer Gläubiger der
deutsche Immobiliensektor ist auch
betroffen
die Frage ist welche Folge kann das für
die deutsche Wirtschaft in diesem
Bereich haben
ja indirekt schwappt das natürlich auch
auf den deutschen Immobiliensektor über
er ist aber durch steigende Zinsen und
sinkende Preise ohne hin schon in einer
schwierigen Phase wirtschaftliche
Probleme aus China kommen eben jetzt
noch dazu und verunsichern die Anleger
der DAX beendet den Handel mit
15.574 Punkten und verliert auf
Wochensicht 1,6 %. China strauchelt
inzwischen in vielen Bereichen hohe
Jugendarbeitslosigkeit zurückhaltender
Konsum und ein schwaches
Wirtschaftswachstum all das wirkt sich
auch auf Deutschland aus aus keinem
anderen Land wird so viel importiert wie
aus China und umgekehrt hängt der
deutsche Export stark ab von der
Wirtschaftskraft der Chinesen Sina meine
vielen Dank für diese Information
die Gewitter sind durch jetzt war der
Deutsche Wetterdienst vor starker
Wärmebelastung morgen in der
Südosthälfte Deutschlands vergangene
Nacht wurden Regionen in Franken noch
besonders hart von schweren Gewittern
mit Starkregen getroffen mehrere
Menschen wurden verletzt es gab viele
Sachschäden allein in Nürnberg wurden
Polizei Feuerwehr und Einsatzkräfte zu
mehr als 1000 einsetzen gerufen
Regenmengen von bis zu 47 Litern pro
Quadratmeter innerhalb einer Stunde
überfluteten Keller und Straßen unter
Führungen
und das war es von uns an diesem Freitag
um kurz nach halb eins meldet sich Laura
barnick mit unserem heute-journal Update
und hier folgt jetzt das ZDF
Politbarometer mit Umfragen zur
aktuellen Stimmung im Land und mit
Matthias fahrnauf
[Musik]
guten Abend willkommen zum
Politbarometer eigentlich sollte es ein
Neustart sein für die regierende Ampel
in Berlin kein Zoff mehr Geschlossenheit
das war das Ziel und das hat nicht
geklappt gleich in der ersten
Kabinettssitzung nach der Sommerpause
kam der Rückfall die grüne
Familienministerin blockierte ein Gesetz
des FDP Finanzministers obwohl der
Entwurf im Vorfeld abgestimmt war das
Hickhack geht also weiter und das
Vertrauen der Bürger nimmt weiter ab
nur 14 Prozent der Befragten glauben die
Ampel kommt bei der Lösung der
anstehenden Probleme eher voran die
große Mehrheit aber 83 Prozent findet
das nicht und zwar mehrheitlich die
Anhänger aller Parteien auch die der
Ampel
die Befragten Stellen der Regierung also
ein denkbar schlechtes halbzeitzeugnis
aus 58 Prozent der Befragten finden die
Ampel macht ihre Arbeit schlecht
cdu/csu können davon aber nicht
profitieren eine unionsgeführte
Regierung würde es auch nicht besser
machen glauben die meisten
die Skepsis der Befragten schließt auch
den cdu-parteichef mit ein
nur 22 Prozent glauben Friedrich Merz
würde sich als Kanzler eignen mehr als
zwei Drittel halten ihn nicht für
geeignet sogar eine Mehrheit der
Unionsanhänger sieht das so
insgesamt fällt die Bewertung der
wichtigsten Politikerinnen und Politiker
kritisch aus mit Ausnahme von
Verteidigungsminister Pistorius liegen
alle im negativen Bereich auch Kanzler
Scholz wird jetzt noch schlechter
bewertet und stürzt ab auf seinen
bisherigen Tiefstwert in unserer Top Ten
wer die 10 wichtigsten Politiker sind
bestimmen die Befragten selbst hier die
Bewertungen auf der Skala von +5 bis -5
nach Sympathie und Leistung
Schlusslicht bleibt Alice Weidel mit
einem Wert von 2,6 etwas schlechter
davor Sahra Wagenknecht -1,1 besser
Friedrich Merz -0,7 deutlich
verschlechtert Robert Habeck minus 0,6
Anna Lena baerbock -0,3 Karl Lauterbach
minus 0,3 alle 3 mit Verlusten Platz 4
für Christian Lindner - 0,2 leicht
schlechter
Markus Söder auf dem dritten Platz minus
0,2 etwas besser
davor Olaf Scholz minus 0,2 mit den
stärksten Verlusten und ganz vorne
weiter Boris Pistorius 1,7 aber auch er
verschlechtert
in der Sonntagsfrage kann sich die SPD
nach ihren Tiefstwert im Juli etwas
verbessern bleibt aber auf Rang 3 wenn
am Sonntag Bundestagswahl wäre kennen
die SPD auf 19% + 2 CDU CSU auf 26% -1
die Grünen erreichten 15 Prozent minus 1
FDP 7 AFD 20 beide unverändert die Linke
läge bei fünf Prozent plus 1
die Ampel hätte also weiterhin keine
parlamentarische Mehrheit reichen würde
es für unionsgeführte Bündnisse entweder
mit Grünen und FDP oder mit SPD und FDP
die Linke müsste um den Einzug ins
Parlament fürchten dabei droht der
Partei derzeit noch weiteres Ungemach im
Richtungsstreit um die Abgeordnete Sarah
Wagenknecht wird sie eine eigene Partei
gründen und was passiert dann mit der
Linken
die große Mehrheit der Befragten sieht
durch den Streit den Fortbestand der
Partei DIE LINKE gefährdet 29 Prozent
sehen diese Gefahr nicht
viel Bürokratie teure Energie zu wenig
Fachkräfte in Deutschland sei die Lage
für Unternehmen aktuell fatal klagen
Wirtschaftsverbände das sehen auch die
Befragten in politbauometer so
61% glauben dass es mit der Wirtschaft
abwärts geht so viele wie noch nie in
diesem Jahr ein Mittel gegen den
Fachkräftemangel könnte ein späterer
Renteneintritt sein das lehnen die
Befragten klar ab
nur 16 Prozent sind der Meinungen zur
Bekämpfung des Fachkräftemangels sollte
der vorzeitige Renteneintritt erschwert
werden 79 Prozent wollen das nicht
es gab nicht nur Streit im Kabinett
diese Woche die Ampel hat sich zum
Beispiel darauf geeinigt Cannabis
begrenzt zu legalisieren das dürfte ihr
eher nicht aus dem Stimmungstief helfen
denn die Meinungen dazu sind nach wie
vor gespalten
eine knappe Mehrheit von 50 Prozent
wünscht sich die begrenzte Legalisierung
45% lehnen sie ab auch bei den Anhängern
der Parteien zeigen sich große
Unterschiede
in Rauschmittel Fragen also kann sich
die Koalition einigen immerhin jetzt
will die selbst ernannte
fortschrittskoalition Fahrt aufnehmen
hin zum viel beschworenen
deutschlandtempo
das war unser Bericht über die Stimmung
im Land die Grafiken und alle
Informationen zu unseren Umfragen finden
Sie wie immer im ZDF Text ab Seite 165
in der ZDF heute App und auf ZDF
heute.de
wie die repräsentativen Umfragen der
Forschungsgruppe Wahlen zustande kommen
Informationen zur Methodik und zu den
Qualitätsstandards finden Sie unter
politbarometer.zdf.de
vielen Dank für Ihr Interesse das
nächste Politbarometer gibt es dann am
15 September nach dem Wetter können Sie
hier ein Konzert von David Garrett auf
Sizilien genießen Ihnen noch einen
entspannten Abend auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter der vergangene
juli war der wärmste Monat seit dem
Daten aufgezeichnet werden und das ist
eine Grafik des kopernikusprogramms und
wir sehen hier in rot die Temperatur
Abweichungen also wo war es wärmer und
wo war es kälter und hier sehen ja über
Nordeuropa und sogar über
Norddeutschland war sogar zu kühl das
sagt aber nichts darüber aus dass der
gesamte Planet deutlich zu heiß war im
Vergleich zu vor industriellen Zeit
sogar fast 1,5 Grad Temperatur
Abweichung in den nächsten Tagen geht's
weiter mit der Hitze von Südwesten kommt
diese zu uns aber wir haben es auch hier
mit einer Kaltfront zu tun so gibt es im
Nordwesten viele Wolken Schauer und auch
mal kräftige Gewitter in der Nacht ist
es fast überall trocken nach ostenden
bildet sich Nebel und ganz im Norden
sind einige Schauer unterwegs bei
tiefsten Temperaturen von angenehmen 14
bis 7 Grad im Südosten 20 bis 22 Grad
nach Westen hin und das ist eine
tropische Nacht morgen dann viel
Sonnenschein nach Süden und Osten aber
zum Nachmittag kommen im Westen Schauer
auf und auch mal einzelne kräftige
Gewitter mit Starkregen durchaus möglich
weil höchsten Temperaturen bis 35 Grad
hier eine extreme Hitzebelastung 26 Grad
an der Nordsee deutlich angenehmer die
nächsten Tage es bleibt weiterhin heiß
bei Temperaturen um 35 Grad und immer
wieder mal Hitze Gewitter damit müssen
sie rechnen damit ein schöner Abend